i know how well you know simone
obviously what was your reaction when
you heard the news today about her
withdrawing
yeah i mean i i feel so
much love for her she is such a hard
worker and i remember
you know being in the gym with her we
had so much fun but
there is just you know this proves that
she's human and
you know it's such a beautiful thing to
see and read everyone's
you know i spoke to her coach cecile
it's so nice to
for america to be behind her and have
she's having all the support
because it is it must be so much
pressure and she's the star of the team
i mean you know there is always a camera
in front of her you could see
she's just even when she's waiting for
the events there's a camera there and i
mean
it must be so hard and she's such a
strong
strong woman and i'm
you know i wish her family her mum and
dad could be there because i know she's
very close to them
to give them a hug and i know that all
of america is definitely behind her
yeah i mean look she's the greatest
gymnast alive you know period end of
discussion
when but just as you said just how she
is under all this pressure and she's
also this incredible competitor
and we know and she's talked about
having pushed through these things in
the past
so what was just your initial reaction
when you saw the news this morning i
mean i was shocked what did you
just first react to i do uh
i mean i thought it was weird because i
i i didn't
i couldn't believe it at first um but at
the same time like
i i've never been to an olympics so i
don't know but you know
the pressure is just must be
out of this world and not only that you
know she's literally
holding you know all of america on her
shoulders it just proves like you know
you don't really know what's going on in
the inside of a person sometimes
no matter how strong they look you know
she's a true sportsman you know she was
giving out the chalk to the other
teammates she was there she was cheering
them on
you know she didn't just leave and you
know that's a true champion
now you were involved in choreographing
her floor routine right can you explain
all that yeah that was so much fun i
mean even when we were
uh when we danced together on desks and
stars we were like oh
it would be so cool to you know to do a
floor routine and
um when she contacted me she's like hey
you know let's do it
so i flew in there we had a lot of fun
together
and clarify for me have we seen that yet
or will we see that if she
continues and does the individuals we
have seen the floor routine
she has performed it she did great at it
i'm not too sure
what her decision is going to be i'm
sure it's a hard one
um you know no matter what whatever she
decides i'm sure everyone's going to be
behind her 100
i definitely know i will um so i don't
know
if if she will continue or she won't
continue
um it's truly up to her have you talked
to her at all
we've messaged like through social
because it's a little hard
um and i know she's going through it a
lot um and i'm sure she's trying to just
kind of like
breathe i know cecile is there with her
her coach
um that you know is acting as a mother
she's there by her side you can see 24
7.
um i've spoken to her um and
yeah i just hope i hope you know
whatever decision she makes it's going
to be
for the right reason because you've had
you know on some level not olympics but
on some level this experience with her
what is she like as a competitor she's
definitely
you know she's very in her head um she
loves
she's a you're right she's a competitor
but with dancing the stars it's a lot
different because i tried to make it
um a fun experience for her i remember
i'll never forget when she said you know
smiling doesn't win you gold medals i
was waiting for you to smile at some of
the compliments
you didn't smiling doesn't win you gold
medals
i remember you defended her when that
smiling thing came into question on
dancing with the stars why was that
important for you
to do that in that moment what were you
seeing that she needed i'm very
protective with my partners no matter
what happens
so whoever my partner is like that's it
there is no wrong she can do no wrong
judges stay away
um i just want him to have a good time
and
um enjoy this journey so i get very
protective and
like i feel like i've known simone for
so many years so like like you said like
when i saw it i was like i i like i
you kind of want to be there to just to
hug her and like
tell her it's going to be okay you know
she is a superstar
i don't know if they'll ever be someone
as good as simone and that just proves
like
so much pressure um you know and someone
can really like
challenge them mentally for the person
at home who maybe can't
understand what it's like to have all
those eyes on you how would you
in layman's terms explain this pressure
oh gosh um you can't i
i really can't explain it but i know
that like once you perform or once you
do your thing
sometimes you go wait did i just do that
like it's like almost a
mental blank because like what you're
doing is just out of this world and
someone actually this this message kind
of went viral on social media someone
said
something like in every event they
should just put like
a regular person in um into the
competition
so it shows you like how difficult what
these people
are doing really is because they make it
look easy right
definitely and simone is one person that
just makes everything look
absolutely easy and it tells you
something that you know
you know she's going through something
mentally when you're that
good and you know something something
you know something like that
happens and i think like you know her
mum and dad aren't there that's
that's a big thing i know they've been
to every olympics
and this is the first time her family's
not there and i
saw like a little thing where she was
talking to them on tv
um and that's a big thing too you know
when the family is not there when you're
used to something like
that's always with you but again like
you know the
beings being winning so many gold medals
and
standing there again one more time like
literally with the whole world on your
shoulders
um it's hard it must be like i don't
think anyone's ever gone through that
and you know at such a young age of 24
to have
all that on your shoulders must be like
i mean
it's proof what happened so i hope you
know whatever decision she makes
if she does the next uh stage of the
competition it's definitely up to her
and
she'll always make the right choice
another really inspirational aspect of
simone is
you know she is back in gymnastics and
taking a stand after
the abuse that so many of these
incredible young gymnasts
suffered and for her to be out there
how much does that inspire you and what
do you think of her speaking about that
openly and continuing to compete
yeah i think you know that's what she
did
is phenomenal i think you know i hope
more with
people out there that have gone through
anything like that
need to open up because like that's a
hundred percent not right
i think she's created herself a very
incredible platform
with talent backed up to to be able to
you know talk about these things
and i hope she's inspired a lot of you
know boys girls
young people out there that um that if
if they're going through something you
know you have to be aware of it and
make sure that you know everyone knows
about it it shouldn't
it shouldn't happen yes 100 um
so we will see what will happen uh with
the incredible simone biles this week
your fingers are crossed for her what
message do you have for her
just to to keep being positive and just
to
the whole world loves you and is
supporting you no matter what